you're watching the GameSpot co-op stage
sponsored by Lego Star Wars The Force
awakens
welcome back to the GameSpot co-op stage
here at e3 2016
brought to you by Lego Star Wars The
Force awakens I'm Jeff kanata and I am
joined by Daniel Dyer ashley Esqueda and
the senior community manager for Crystal
Dynamics Megan Marie it's great to be
here thanks for having me well we are
excited to have you because I was not
aware of this and it kind of makes me
feel alright
yeah but Tomb Raider turns 20 years old
this year it's not crazy it's crazy it's
amazing though it's a big year for it
yeah so yeah 1996 the first Tomb Raider
came out yes and here we are 20 years
later and it's still going strong I mean
my my video game show DLC we named Rhys
the Tomb Raider as our game of the Year
last year that's so wonderful to hear
yes so that is that is a franchise that
is definitely still going strong yeah
talk a little bit about this this big
anniversary for you guys so throughout
the year we're trying to do a whole
bunch of different celebrations to just
again celebrate what Tomb Raider and
Lara Croft means to the industry and
means to the fans and so we've announced
a couple of different projects firstly
we came up with a really cool logo and I
love this it's a it's a very carefully
visually designed so that it doesn't
look quite like classic Lara or or you
know the modern review did Lara you know
is it a ponytail or is it a braid or is
it pants or is it shorts and so it's
just really cool celebration love and
Laura yeah but you recognize the
silhouette like instantly you know
that's Lara Croft and so that was
something really fun that we did to
create this this banner for our
celebrations and then we announced a
couple of projects already where we have
an official 20th anniversary book that
covers the the breaths of the industry
of the the franchise from video games to
comics to the movies in the fans there's
a hundred pages dedicated to just our
fans in this book which is something
that I'm pretty proud of because our
community is wonderful we also announced
a music suite the Tomb Raider music
suite which is the original composer
from the first games the first three
games Nathan create
he's reimagining the the tracks a
concert and it's gonna be really cool so
we have a couple of other 20th
anniversary announcements them so cool
that's organizing and other things
coming up in the future so we're trying
to stagger a bunch of celebrations
throughout the year and and really dive
into that nostalgia that's great I
actually as a as a girl gamer Lara's
probably has a very strong place in your
heart yeah I mean I the thing is is
there were so few female protagonists I
mean I really identified as a kid with
samus I mean Samus Aran is the jam-like
that was it and and then it became Lara
Croft like that sort of ushered in my
teenage years was spent like hanging out
with Lara and in all of the different
doing puzzles and everything in tombs
and for me I think it was really
refreshing and I didn't realize it at
the time it's just one of those things
that now looking back on it it was so
exciting to me to see somebody that was
not just tough or only sexy or only
smart or only one thing it was all of
those things and I've always felt that
you know being obviously like growing up
as a gamer who loves games and is also a
girl like people always thought that was
really weird but I was just like we'll
look at Laura Croft like Laura Croft is
a hero so why can't I be in games like
so it's always the thing that I felt
really strongly about like I championed
that and I thought that that was really
important that I didn't just have to be
oh she's really tough but she's not sexy
like I can be both and I I just really I
really appreciate that I mean that's
like a cool that's the best thing about
Lara Croft it's it's funny no because I
grew up very much a similar story and I
know I hear that story I got across a
lot of especially women in gaming but I
grew up and she was she inspired me in
so many ways to be brave and bold and to
you know really pushed me even to try my
hand in a male-dominated industry
working in gaming and surance but the
funny thing is now she's younger than me
she was like she was my dad
but now in the review rebooted universe
she's younger than me but it's I draw I
still love I love both versions so much
you know like classic Laura and scare me
to be brave and strong and build a tank
top the shorts that I know wears like I
mean it's such a great iconic thing you
know and I don't you know at the time
you see it and a meowt looks so silly
like everything in it but it's like oh
man it was so like realistic it cool and
wow look at like she's jumping and
running and do all this crazy stuff like
I am I loved it and it was it was really
important I again like you don't realize
it at the time it was really important
to me yeah you can necessarily
articulate it like it's a 12 year old I
didn't know why representation but I
loved it now I look back and it's like I
didn't have much in common with her a
British gun-toting archaeologist right
very well but she was brunette and she
was a woman and and now she looks up to
us yeah well I think that this is the
new la rebooted Laura continues to
inspire me especially because she she
shows true bravery through adversity and
shock teaches you that like
vulnerability and being human isn't a
bad thing it's a way for bigamy witness
definitely something I draw inspiration
from - yeah Danny I'm curious it seems
to me that the the pattern of the path
of this franchise right mirrors in a lot
of ways the pattern and path of the
video game industry as a whole here we
have a character and a series that
started as basically a riff on Indiana
Jones or something very simplistic and
now these modern these last two games
are so much more nuanced and so much
richer and so much deeper and have a
character that is really written as as
well as any film character is and I
think that shows where we went as an
industry right yeah totally I mean there
aren't many game franchises which last
two decades like just across the board
especially not one that's been led by a
singular character so in that respect
Tomb Raider is incredibly sort of
singular that singular in that respect I
mean I think about my own love of that
franchise when I first got a PlayStation
that the Lara Croft enumerator was the
franchise that I attached myself to
immediately I remember like a Christmas
I could only ever get one I get a one
video game right that was my present I
remember I guess it was 98 then so Tomb
Raider 3 yes
year at getting getting skill my sister
had to pick it up in England because it
was no confidence my mother was like why
you but to miss she thought it was a
game at that grave-digging
robbers have to steal from all these
dead people
right I mean there was a dark path in
the middle there with Angel of Darkness
and some of those games didn't really
hit off really well
I mean Crystal Dynamics picked up that
ball and when they when they sort of
reinvented Tomb Raider
I mean twice now base yeah but I mean
that the foundation was there in the
foundation is what made it so strong and
core design did a wonderful job in
creating this game where you could
actually interact with these incredible
3d environments that I think you know
it's easy Lara Croft is amazing and you
know obviously like she's the reason
that I fell in love with the games first
and foremost but the world and the
technology and the environment then the
puzzles and t-rex's and all these things
like that the gameplay was so incredible
in that foundation that they laid you
know allowed us to really run with the
franchise when we became the stewards of
it and so it's it's been an incredible
journey looking through looking looking
through it it's been really incredible
it's it's an amazing time period and you
know here we are
III and there's so much excitement
around a game like got a war that's
being sort of rebooted yeah I feel like
what we're seeing from Ghana war is very
exciting but wouldn't have happened if
there hadn't have been a Tomb Raider you
know it's it I think it learned from
that it's in that same well so many
games were inspired by that I mean
uncharted like I mean it seems like
amazing incredible games yes literally
like this is this time is a flat circle
like you think about all these amazing
games that are these action-adventure
games that have some puzzle solving
elements and them in really Tomb Raider
was the genesis of that in terms of 3d
gaming on PlayStation and I mean this
was that was it and so now to see kind
of what it's evolved to I mean we're all
so lucky to be gaming right now like to
head see these amazing games and it's
not just one franchise to go so many I
mean that's a very good point like for a
long time there were 3d action games but
they were predominantly shooting
shooting shooting and I mean you go back
and play the first Tomb Raider game the
amount of downtime in that
for large most of the game you're spent
exploring the isolation is don't get
that a lot
there's a wolf maybe every once in a
while but yeah bears yeah so it's
terrifying barrage yes we got in height
in the water and then in uncharted 4
you've got these long stretches where
you're not doing any exploring climbing
like you know doing doing Nathan E Drake
but Drake efface all he needs that was a
butler you can lock in the fridge and
one of the best moments it speaks to
that ^ characters and characters that
persevere right I mean I think you could
put Laura up against you know alongside
pac-man and Mario you know and she is
she is one of that pantheon of
characters that has been around that
long and endures and continues to be
relevant and continues to represent I
mean we've had films of Tomb Raider but
it represents video games I think and I
think that she definitely transcends
gaming even though it's you know being
so important and pivotal within gaming I
mean going to the the - comic series a
Top Cow indoor Dark Horse and the movies
and we are having another movie coming
out and we've got an animated there was
an animated series at one point in time
over ten you know models and so there's
there's a lot of just it crossed
boundaries and it you know Lara Croft in
1997 was on the cover of the face which
was this British fashion magazine and it
was the first virtual character to be on
the face and they you know allow her to
interrupt the masthead and it was just
like this moment when they realized that
Laura was really transcending gaming
that she was a pop culture icon so
what's next I mean you mentioned a new
film we've heard of casting on that yeah
well what's next for the video game
franchise that we you know she just
continuing to rise I've been doing I
think there's some destiny to be
fulfilled but I say anything more than
that
so it's just it's an exciting time to
work on the franchise and knowing that
the future is really bright and that you
know this year is all about celebration
is really great yeah it's especially for
longtime fans I'm right now on social
channels we're doing every two weeks
where we're doing a deep dive on another
game and so right now we're doing Tomb
Raider 3 and every day we're posting
this little tidbit and a lot of stuff
it's really fun
because I wrote the 20th anniversary
book and in that process of writing it I
uncovered a bunch of stuff that even I
didn't know and I kind of thought that I
knew I knew I thought I knew a lot about
the franchise but there was all this
stuff that I had never even heard of and
so we're taking some of those kid myths
and we're putting them online and it's
just this huge nostalgia trip
everybody's having so much fun with it
and so we you know uncovered like a this
tomb raider 3 launch trailer that was
only shown at the the localized launch
trailer at the localized launch event in
London and we found it and rezzed it up
and put it online so we're finding all
of these things that are treasures from
the last 20 years are you able to go
back and play those games are they are
they available ah damn dog you can go to
see me operating your steam down steam
it's really oh I don't know that and I
think they're great I've replayed Tomb
Raider 2 a couple years ago and it held
up well I remember it was as hard as I
remember all the fire traps terrible 20
years of Lara Croft 20 years of Tomb
Raider thanks for joining us where can
people find out more about the year-long
festivities
yeah well swim Raider calm and then
specifically we have a hub on our Tomb
Raider tumblr account so it's Tomb
Raider tumbler calm and we're keeping it
an updated schedule but just use the
hashtag Tomb Raider 20 that's what all
of our posts are through awesome well we
got lots more coming at you from e3 so
stick around and keep us tuned in